>>> HERE IN A FEW HOURS,
PROSECUTORS WILL RESUME THEIR
CASE IN THE MURDER TRIAL OF
THREE MEN CHARGED IN THE DEATH
OF AHMAUD ARBERY.
THE JUDGE MONDAY REJECTING THE
DEFENSE REQUEST FOR A MISTRIAL
AND BLASTING ONE ATTORNEY FOR
COMMENTS OBJECTING TO BLACK
PASTORS BEING IN THE COURTROOM.
CNN'S MARTIN SAVAGE IS LIVE IN
BRUNSWICK, GEORGIA.
MARTIN, TELL US THE LATEST HERE.
>> Reporter: MORNING, BRIANNA.
YEAH, FOR A TIME, IT LOOKED LIKE
THIS CASE WAS GOING TO COME TO
AN ABRUPT AND UGLY ENDING.
NOT BECAUSE OF WHAT WAS SAID ON
THE WITNESS STAND BUT BECAUSE OF
WHAT WAS HEARD AND SEEN IN THE
COURTROOM.
>> CONTEXT OF THIS TRIAL, WE
OBJECT TO PRESENCE IN THE PUBLIC
GALLERY INSIDE THE COURTROOM.
>> Reporter: AN EXPLOSIVE
MORNING IN THE TRIAL OF THE
THREE MEN ACCUSED OF MURDERING
ARBERY, WITH A SMOLDERING DEBATE
SPURRED BY DEFENSE ATTORNEYS
OVER BLACK PASTORS IN THE
COURTROOM.
>> IF SOMEBODY IS IN THE GALLERY
HERE AS A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC,
THAT'S THEIR RIGHT TO BE HERE.
I'M NOT GOING TO TRACK
INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO COME IN AND OUT OF THIS
COURTROOM.
>> Reporter: DEFENSE ATTORNEY
KEVIN GOUGH OBJECTING TO
REVEREND JESSE JACKSON'S
PRESENCE IN THE GALLERY.
>> HOW MANY PASTORS DOES THE
ARBERY FAMILY HAVE?
WE HAD THE REVEREND AL SHARPTON
HERE EARLIER LAST WEEK.
WHICH PASTOR IS NEXT?
IS RAPHAEL WARNOCK GOING TO BE
THE NEXT PERSON APPEARING THIS
AFTERNOON?
WE DON'T KNOW.
YOUR HONOR, I WOULD SUBMIT, WITH
ALL RESPECT TO THE REVEREND
JESSE JACKSON, THAT THIS IS NO
DIFFERENT THAN BRINGING IN
POLICE OFFICERS OR UNIFORMED
PRISON GUARDS IN A SMALL TOWN,
WHERE A YOUNG BLACK MAN HAS BEEN
ACCUSED OF ASSAULTING A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER OR
CORRECTIONS OFFICER.
>> Reporter: THIS, A RECURRING
ISSUE FOR WILLIAM "RODDIE"
BRYAN'S DEFENSE ATTORNEY, WHERE
RACE HAS BEEN FRONT AND CENTER.
JACKSON ARRIVED AT COURT MONDAY
MORNING AFTER GOUGH SAID THIS
THURSDAY.
>> WE DON'T WANT ANY MORE BLACK
PASTORS COMING IN HERE OR OTHER
JESSE JACKSON, WHOEVER WAS IN
HERE EARLIER THIS WEEK, SITTING
WITH THE VICTIM'S FAMILY, TRYING
TO INFLUENCE THE JURY IN THIS
CASE.
A BUNCH OF FOLKS CAME HERE
DRESSED LIKE COLONEL SANDERS
WITH WHITE MASKS IN THE BACK,
THAT WOULD BE --
>> Reporter: HE WAS ACTUALLY
REFERENCING THE REVEREND AL
SHARPTON, WHO WAS IN THE
COURTROOM ON WEDNESDAY TO
SUPPORT ARBERY'S FAMILY.
GOUGH APOLOGIZED TO THE COURT ON
FRIDAY BUT BROUGHT UP THE ISSUE
AGAIN MONDAY.
THE JUDGE REBUKED THE DEFENSE
ATTORNEY.
>> NOW WITH INDIVIDUAL
MEMBERS -- OR INDIVIDUALS COMING
INTO THE COURTROOM, I WILL SAY
THAT IS DIRECTLY IN RESPONSE,
MR. GOUGH, TO STATEMENTS YOU
MADE, WHICH I FIND
REPREHENSIBLE.
THE COLONEL SANDERS STATEMENT
YOU MADE LAST WEEK, I WOULD
SUGGEST, MAY BE SOMETHING THAT
HAS INFLUENCED WHAT IS GOING ON
HERE.
YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND,
EVERYBODY, THAT YOUR WORDS IN
THIS COURTROOM HAVE AN IMPACT ON
A LOT OF WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> Reporter: AHMAUD ARBERY'S
NEIGHBOR, CAROL FLOWERS, WAS
CALLED AS A WITNESS.
DURING THE TESTIMONY, ARBERY'S
MOTHER TRIED WHEN A PHOTO OF HIM
ALIVE WAS SHOWN.
AFTER THE BREAK, GOUGH ASKED THE
JUDGE TO AGAIN TAKE ACCOUNT OF
EVERY PERSON IN THE GALLERY,
SAYING HE WAS FEARFUL CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS COULD SWAY THE JURY
BY BEING PRESENT.
ADDING --
>> YOUR HONOR, THE CASE LAW OUT
THERE IN MOB CASES, IN OTHER
CASES, DEMONSTRATES ALL THE WAYS
THAT PRESENCE IN A GALLERY CAN
INFLUENCE JURORS IN A CASE.
I CERTAINLY DON'T MEAN TO
SUGGEST THAT AL SHARPTON OR
JESSE JACKSON OR ANY OTHER
PASTOR BELONG TO A MOB.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT ORGANIZED BEHAVIOR
BY WHOEVER OUTSIDE THE
COURTHOUSE LEADING UP TO THIS
CASE, WHERE WE HAVE ALL THESE
COMMUNITY LEADERS FEARFUL THAT
THE CITY IS GOING TO BURN DOWN.
>> Reporter: THAT'S WHEN ALL
THREE DEFENSE ATTORNEYS MOVED
FOR A MISTRIAL, CLAIMING THEIR
CLIENTS WERE NOT RECEIVING A
FAIR TRIAL.
ALSO CITING ARBERY'S MOTHER'S
EMOTIONS.
>> BASED ON THAT OUTBURST, THE
COURT IS NOT GRANTING A
MISTRIAL.
>> Reporter: JACKSON SAID THIS
LATER OUTSIDE THE COURTROOM.
>> CHALLENGING MY RIGHT TO BE
THE JUDGE.
IT'S MY CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
BE THERE.
I HAVE A MORAL OBLIGATION TO BE
THERE.
I HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN NEED,
BACKS ARE AGAINST THE WALL.
IT'S WHAT WE DO.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP SERVING THIS
FAMILY AS A PRIORITY AND FOCUS
OF OURS NOW.
>> Reporter: THE TRIAL RESUMED
WITH A SERIES OF FORENSIC
EXPERTS TEIFYING ABOUT
FINGERPRINTS AND ENHANCEMENTS
MADE TO A CELL PHONE VIDEO.
THE VIDEO SHOWS ARBERY'S DEATH
IN 2020 AFTER HE WAS CHASED BY
GREGORY AND TRAVIS McMICHAEL,
ARMED FATHER AND SON, AND THEIR
NEIGHBOR, WILLIAM "RODDIE"
BRYAN.
THEY PURSUED THE 23-YEAR-OLD IN
PICKUP TRUCKS BEFORE CORNERING
HIM, AND TRAVIS McMICHAEL
SHOOTING HIM.
THE WEAPON USED IN THE SHOOTING
WAS SHOWN, EVEN HOLES IN
ARBERY'S SHIRT.
>> CAN YOU SHOW HOW CLOSE THE
GUN WOULD BE TO THAT T-SHIRT?
>> Reporter: AN EXPERT FROM THE
GEORGIA BUREAU OF INVESTIGATIONS
TESTIFIED ARBERY WAS SHOT AT
CLOSE RANGE.
>> THE END OF THE SHOTGUN WAS
VERY CLOSE TO THAT FABRIC WHEN
IT WAS FIRED.
TO HAVE SOMETHING THAT LARGE, IT
HAD TO BE MADE BY THE, IN MY
OPINION, MADE BY THE GAS FROM
THE TEARING OF THE LARGE AMOUNT
OF GAS THAT EXITS THE END OF THE
BARREL OF THE WEAPON.
ALSO OBSERVED IS THE ROLLING OF
THE FABRIC WHERE THE EDGES OF IT
ARE SEARED AND ROLLED UP.
>> Reporter: ARBERY'S MOTHER
REPORTEDLY KEPT HER EYES CLOSED
DURING THE REPLAYS OF THE CELL
PHONE VIDEO OF HER SON'S LAST
MOMENTS.
SHE LATER SAID SHE WAS SATISIED
BY THE PROSECUTION'S CASE.
>> THE STATE IS DOING A VERY
FANTASTIC JOB IN PRESENTING THE
EVIDENCE IN THE CASE.
I'M VERY CONFIDENT WE WILL GET
JUSTICE FOR AHMAUD.
>> Reporter: AS HE WAS GETTING
INTO HIS CAR LAST EVENING AFTER
TRIAL, I CAUGHT UP WITH ATTORNEY
KEVIN GOUGH.
I ASKED HIM WHAT'S NEXT?
HE IMPLIED HE WAS GOING TO BE
BUSY LAST NIGHT WORKING ON A NEW
MOTION.
WHAT THAT MOTION IS ABOUT, WE'RE
NOT QUITE CLEAR, BUT IT'S PRETTY
OBVIOUS WE HAVEN'T HEARD THE
LAST ON THE ISSUE OF BLACK
PASTORS AND THE THREAT HE
BELIEVES THEY POSE TO
BRIANNA AND JOHN.
>> MARTIN, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> JOINING ME NOW IS CHARLES
COLEMAN, CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY
AND FORMER PROSECUTOR AND TRIAL
ATTORNEY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US THIS MORNING.
WE DON'T WANT ANY MORE BLACK
PASTORS HERE.
HOW MANY BLACK PASTORS DOES THE
ARBERY FAMILY HAVE?
WHAT'S THE STRATEGY BEHIND WHAT
DEFENSE ATTORNEY KEVIN GOUGH IS
DOING?
>> THE STRATEGY IS SIMPLY TO TRY
TO APPEAL TO THE LOWEST COMMON
DENOMINATOR, THE LOWEST FACTOR
HE CAN, IN TERMS OF THROWING OUT
A HAIL MARY, IN HOPES THAT
SOMEBODY IS GOING TO LEAK
SOMETHING TO THE JURY AND
POTENTIALLY GET SOMEONE ON THE
SAME WAVELENGTH HE IS.
HE IS GOING TO GO ALL OUT IN
TERMS OF PUTTING DOWN THE DOG
WHISTLE AND PICKING UP THE BULL
HORN ABOUT WHAT IT IS TO SPOUT
RACIST RHETORIC AS A MEANS TO
TRYING TO CONNECT TO THE 11
WHITE JURORS, AS WELL AS THE 1
BLACK.
I HAVE LONG SAID THAT RACE IS
THE 13th JUROR IN THIS CASE.
IT IS BEING HELD IN BRUNSWICK,
GEORGIA.
FROM THE OUTSET, WHAT WE SAW
WITH RESPECT TO JURY SELECTION
AND HOW THIS TRIAL HAS
PROCEEDED, AND WITH BRYAN'S
REPEATED -- SORRY, WITH GOUGH'S
REPEATED ATTEMPTS TO KEEP
CERTAIN PEOPLE OUT OF THIS
COURTROOM, IT IS UNDEANIABLE
THAT HE IS -- UNDEIABLE THAT HE
IS PLAYING THE RACE CARD FOR HIS
CLIENT.
>> YOU CAN'T DENY IT.
WILLIAM BARBER LAST WEEK SAID,
I'M NOT A BLACK PASTOR.
I'M A PASTOR.
>> RIGHT.
>> I'M A PASTOR.
THESE ARE PASTORS WHO ARE IN THE
COURTROOM THERE.
WHAT THE DEFENSE IS DOING IS
JUST BLATANT.
THERE'S NO SUBTLETY TO IT.
I WANT TO FOCUS IN ON SOMETHING
YOU SAID THERE THOUGH.
BECAUSE ALL THESE SPEECHES HAD
BEEN MADE WITH THE JURY OUT OF
THE COURTROOM.
>> SURE.
>> OUT OF THE COURTROOM.
SO HE'S GOT TO BE THINKING THEN,
OR HOPING, THAT, SOMEHOW, THEY
CATCH WIND OF THIS.
>> NOT JUST THAT.
I THINK THAT'S A BIG PART OF IT.
I THINK HE IS HOPING THAT, AT
SOME POINT, SOMETHING LEAKS.
IF HE IS ABLE TO CONNECT TO ONE
OF THE JURORS ARE WHAT HE SAID.
NOT DIRECTLY, BUT THROUGH WHAT
IS GOING ON IN THE NEWS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IT.
IT IS BEING TALKED ABOUT
EVERYWHERE.
HE IS HOPING SOMEONE GETS WIND
OF IT AND BEGINS TO THINK ABOUT
IT AS THEY LOOK ACROSS THE ROOM
INTO THE GALLERY OF THAT
COURTROOM AND SEE THE PROMINENT
FIGURES THERE.
THERE IS ANOTHER ANGLE AS WELL.
HE IS TRYING TO DO WHATEVER HE
CAN TO MAKE AN ISSUE FOR APPEAL
OUT OF, FOR HIS CLIENT IN CASE
HE IS CONVICTED.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS A VIABLE
ISSUE FOR APPEAL OR ONE HE CAN
WIN ON APPEAL IF HIS CLIENT IS
CONVICTED, BUT IT IS SOMETHING
HE IS TRYING TO CREATE A RECORD
AROUND IN CASE THAT HAPPENS.
>> THE JUDGE CALLED IT
REPREHENSIBLE.
>> YES.
>> WHAT MORE COULD OR SHOULD THE
JUDGE BE DOING IN YOUR MIND, IF
ANYTHING?
>> I THINK THE JUDGE DID THE
RIGHT THING IN TERMS OF CALLING
IT REPREHENSIBLE, DENYING THE
MISTRIAL, AND CALLING IT
DIRECTLY.
1857 DRED SCOTT VERSUS STANFORD.
IN THAT CASE, THE UNITED STATES
SAID THE BLACK MAN IN AMERICA
HAD NO RIGHTS WHICH THE WHITE
MAN WAS BOUND TO RESPECT.
I THINK ABOUT THE WHISPERS OF
DRED SCOTT ALONG WITH WHAT IS
GOING ON WITH THIS CASE.
AHMAUD ARBERY IN THE EYES OF THE
McMICHAEL FAMILY AND MR. BRYAN
DIDN'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO GO INTO
A HOUSE, LOOK AT WHAT WAS GOING
ON, AND GO JOGGING.
NOW ACCORDING TO MR. BRYAN'S
ATTORNEY, MR. GOUGH, AL SHARPTON
AND OTHER BLACK PASTORS DO NOT
HAVE THE RIGHT TO SIT IN A TRIAL
AND COMFORT AHMAUD ARBERY'S
FAMILY.
THAT FAMILY DESERVES TO BE
COMFORTED BY ANYONE WHO THEY
CHOOSE AND ANYONE WHO IS SITTING
THERE NOT TRYING TO INFLUENCE
THAT TRI